in uh innovators another book of yours
that I love you write about individuals
and about groups so one of the questions
the book addresses is is it individuals
or is it groups that turn the tides of
history when Henry Kissinger was on the
shuttle missions for the Middle East
peace is the first book I ever wrote he
said when I was a professor at
Harvard I thought that history was
determined by great forces and groups of
people but when I see it up close I see
what a difference an individual can make
he's talking about Sadat and gold Mayer
probably talking about himself too or at
least in his mind and um we biographers
have this dirty secret that we know we
distort history a bit by making the
narrative to driven by an
individual but sometimes it is driven by
an individual musk is a case like that
and sometimes as I did with the
innovators there's teams and people who
build on each other and Gordon Moore and
Bob noise then getting Andy Grove and
doing the microchip which then comes out
and wnc and jobs find it at uh some
electronic store and they decide to
build the
Apple um and so sometimes there are
flows of forces and groups of people I
guess I a little bit on the side of
looking at what a Steve Jobs and Elon
Musk and Albert Einstein can
do um and I also try to figure out if
they hadn't been around would the forces
of history and the groups of people have
done it without them that's a good
historical question as a you know
somebody who loves history and you think
about special relativity one of the 1905
papers even after he writes it it's four
years before before people truly get
what he's saying which is it's not just
how you observe time is relative it's
time itself is relative and on the
general theory which he does a decade
later I'm not sure we would gotten that
yet how what about moving us into the
era of an iPhone in which it's so
beautiful that you can't live without a
thousand songs in your pocket email and
uh the internet in your pocket and the
phone uh there a lot of brain dead
people from Panasonic to Motorola who
didn't get that and it may have been a
while I certainly think it's true of the
era of electric vehicles Jim and Ford
all the great people there they crushed
the bolt and I mean that literally they
ended up smashing them because they
decided to discontinue it likewise
nobody was sending up Rockets our space
shuttle was about to be grounded 12
years
ago and so must does
things and there'll be people who say
and read the book if they read the book
they'll see the full story but they say
it wasn't musk who did Tesla it was
Martin Ard or Mark tarpening no no no
you know there were people who had
helped create you know the shells of
companies and other things and they were
all deserved to be called co-founders
but the guy who actually gets us to a
million electric vehicles a year is Elon
Musk and without him I don't think we
look if anybody five years from now buys
a car that's gasoline powered we'll
think that's quaint you know that's odd
I mean suddenly we've changed we're not
going to do it 90% of that is Elon
Musk